14h cet après midi à la mairie de
guyancourt ont fait le point sur les
intempéries des jours précédents et
surtout celles à venir une à trois
réunions par jour
[Musique]
c'est des moments importants puisque on
a l'ensemble effectivement des services
de la ville qui sont mobilisés on permet
de faire le point sur la météo sur la
danse effectivement la météo de voir
aussi le travail que les agents de la
ville font sur les voiries il faut
penser à accueillir les enfants dans les
crèches continue à les garder dans les
crèches ou dans les écoles
bien après l'heure effectivement de
fermeture pour sécuriser les parents une
évaluation presque heure par heure
depuis mardi après midi ce jeudi une
inquiétude apparaît le sel 40 tonnes ont
été déversées dans les rues la moitié du
stock communal on a recommandé à 80 par
mois semaine prochaine on espère les
avoir un grosse modo pour bien des
salles et suit un événement comme hier
la ville sur les axes primaires
secondaires et également le tout ce
qu'ils aient accès aux services publics
nous faut une journée et demie avec un
travail ininterrompu de la saleuse et
des hommes à pied 44 à 100 agents tous
services confondus sont mobilisées jour
et nuit
la neige devrait revenir dans les
yvelines au vendredi la salle aux
clients courtoise reprendra du service
dès trois heures du matin